hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the key points that julian the
emperor
also known as julie in the apostate
really wants to drive home
in his oration number six to the
uneducated cynics
is precisely that that these people
calling themselves cynics
are uneducated that means undeveloped
they have mistaken ideas about what
they're doing and they're acting
as in essence like a bunch of jackasses
for no good reason actually to their own
harm and the harm of other people and
they're
missing the whole point of the
cynic philosophy as a philosophy
of practice a philosophy that is
lived out and so we can ask well what is
the point of cynic philosophy and here's
where
you could bring cynics in and and put
them to the test if they say something
like well
i'm just holding up the mirror to
society man you know like all the
hippies used to do
probably not a real cynic if they're
like well you know this is going to make
me
an influencer on pick whatever social
media
you like probably not a real cynic
if they say oh i just want to withdraw
from everybody
and everything and get away from it all
that's not really being a cynic
either there's there's more to it
according to julian at least and i think
that he's he's probably
on the right track when we look at the
examples of antisthenes
or diogenes or other classic
cynics so what what is the point of
cynic philosophy he tells us point blank
it is like with every philosophy
passes philosophy happiness eudaimonia
the thing that that ancient greek
philosophy
was centered around and really this this
runs throughout
roman philosophy you know into the
middle ages
and what what does this look like then
for the cynic
so one formulation that he
uses is living in accordance with
nature which sounds vaguely stoic right
because the stoic said similar things
and then he says uh not in line not in
accordance with the
opinion of the vulgar crowd or multitude
so not common opinions
by the way i want to point one thing out
in here
he does he's not saying that it's
automatically
bad to um believe the crowd he actually
says
for people who are you know
not that that learned it can be a good
thing it's
better than having no principles
whatsoever
it's it's you know better than than just
being
entirely on their own right because
we're social creatures
but for the people who have genuine
knowledge who have developed their
minds we should try to figure out what
our nature really is and this goes back
to the self-knowledge thing that he
began with at the beginning so
that's a key thing and that leads into
talking about
self-knowledge knowledge of what we are
what kind of creature we are
we are not just plants we are
not just animals we have a faculty
of reason we are rational souls
connected with bodies right and we can
look at the faculties of the soul
and the parts of the body and figure out
how we ought to live
what makes sense for us as human beings
we also want to have freedom from
passion if possible apathea
right that is not being moved by things
like as he brings up
envy or wrath or anger
or all sorts of other passions
desire right we don't want to be steered
around by these things we don't want
them
to as we could say run the show
dictate to us who we're going to be and
we also want to try to as much as
possible be like the gods
the gods are rational the gods
have this sort of freedom they they
don't indulge themselves
contrary to you know the old homeric
stories
um you know he says freedom from passion
is the end in the aim this is equivalent
to being a god and this can take place
in many
different ways he's also got this great
discussion about
being free more generally not being
a slave so we we have to take a look at
what he's
saying here he tells us that
for mankind freedom is the beginning of
all good things
what people are always calling good how
can you deny it property
money birth physical strength beauty
and in a word everything of that sort
when divorced from freedom
are surely blessings that belong not to
him who merely seems to enjoy him
but to him who is that man's master
so think about this money property
beauty
pleasure those things can be taken away
from you
in an instant or perhaps over a long
process
but if somebody else is in control of
them you're not really free
if that's where you put your value you
can enjoy them
as antisthenes you know diz uh in in his
own
time talking about you know enjoying
fine wine at a symposium
but if you if you desire it if you
hanker after it if that's what you
orient your life around
you're not really free he tells us that
who are we to regard as a slave is it
the person that we buy
for a certain amount of money and he
says you'll probably say
that such a person is truly a slave why
because we paid down money for him
and he says well in that case prisoners
of wars are saying who is really a slave
is the person over whom another person
has the power to compel them to do
whatever they order
and if they refuse to punish them and in
the word of the poet to inflict grievous
pains upon them so we can be slaves even
if we are
rich even if we're influential even if
we're
powerful we can still be slaves slaves
to our appetites
slaves to whoever panders to those
appetites
and he says consider next whether we
have not as many masters as there are
persons
whom we are obliged to conciliate in
order to not
suffer pain or annoyance from being
punished by them right there's
all sorts of ways of of losing
out on on things so you know the goal of
cynic philosophy is
freedom as much as we can happiness
living in accordance with nature being
able to develop our rational faculties
he also has this great discussion he
says well where does happiness reside in
us
where should we be looking for it should
it be in an external things
like our possessions or even our body
you know if you're good looking should
that be where your happiness is
you're looking in the mirror all the
time nowadays you can like take
selfies with your phone oh look at me
with this filter
look at me over here here's a cornfield
behind me
or you know whatever other flower thing
is
is you know sunflowers for a while for
the going thing right
oh look at me well that can go away very
quickly that's not really where you
should be putting all of your happiness
now is it and it not only is it stupid
because it's an
insecure thing it's rather
arbitrary your looks aren't really you
or if they are you that's pretty sad
right a cynic would would tell you so he
goes on
and he tells us um here we go
we must not be too busy about happiness
as if it were hidden away
outside ourselves isn't that an
interesting turn of phrase
as if happiness is something we have to
go on a scavenger hunt for oh is it over
there
is it over here no that maybe it's in a
magazine maybe it's in a website
maybe uh you know some some self-help
guru
has the happiness that you're looking
for or an investment
person right he says we must not be busy
about it as if it were outside of
ourselves
neither the eagle nor the plane tree nor
anything else that has life
vainly troubles itself about wings or
leaves of gold
or that it shoots maybe of silver it's
or it stings and spurs of iron or rather
adamant but where nature in the
beginning adorned them with such things
they consider with
that if they're only strong and
serviceable for speed or defense they're
good
so isn't it absurd when a human being
tries to find happiness
somewhere outside of our self and and
you could respond he doesn't do that
but you could respond and say yeah but
other animals don't have technology
they don't have a society we we have
culture
we can look at other people and be like
that guy's higher
that guy's lower you know vote him up
vote him down or pick whatever else
you you like and he says
it's absurd when a human being tries to
find happiness somewhere outside of
themselves
and thinks that wealth birth influence
of friends and anything
of that sort is of the utmost importance
why he says we have a soul that does not
resemble
other animals we are different we are
rational and he says whether it be
different in essence or not different in
essence but superior in its activity
i don't really care what matters is that
the
our minds the best and noblest part of
ourselves
that is where happiness resides it's not
only
in the soul it's in the best part of
our soul so then that leads us to a
question okay so we've figured out what
happiness is
where it resides how do we get it what
are the means for
acquiring happiness and there's a number
of important means
i think you can think of these as
self-reinforcing or mutually reinforcing
right
so the first thing that he says at a
couple different points is
following reason paying attention to
what
reason says as opposed to just following
our
appetites or listening to what any you
know
schmuck who happens to have a whole
bunch of followers
or some tv personality they don't know
necessarily what's good for us follow
reason follow rational people as well
and the more that you do that
the closer you're going to get to
happiness so you have to
follow the dictates of reason and as he
says the god within
mind noose the the higher faculty
that reveals to us what we ought to be
doing what we ought to be thinking and
this is a you know he says this at
multiple points
this is quite important he says that the
cynic
is characterized by reason and a certain
plan
of life right and we also
use that faculty of reason to do some of
these other things
so another thing that we need to do and
there's many different ways to do this
is to subdue and subordinate the body
and the emotional parts of the soul
so it's not just letting the soul do
whatever it wants
we have to have a well structured soul
right um but subordinating the body is
very important and he gives some
examples he says
consider whether diogenes did not above
all of her men all other men profess
this belief that you know we need to
cultivate happiness
he freely exposed his body to hardships
so he might make it stronger than it was
by nature he
allowed himself to act only as the light
of reason shows us we ought to act
and the perturbations that attack the
soul and are derived from the body
he did not take into account at all thus
by means of this discipline
right by disciplining the self
and the body he made his body more
vigorous than any of those who contended
for the prize of a crown in the game
and his soul was so disposed he was
happy and a king no less
if not even more than the great king as
the greeks used to call him
in those days by which they met the gree
the king of persia
right so that's one set of things
that we can do he also talks about
the need to
make sure that we subordinate the
parts of our soul that are striving
after sensual pleasures that are
striving after honor
the you know the appetite
and thumatic part of the soul it's very
important to
get those in reign and if if we don't do
that we're going to be
in in trouble now does that mean we have
to be like totally
abstentious no he says diogenes would
sometimes visit a courtesan
uh but you know just to satisfy a few
things and then and then move on
after that right so we could develop uh
virtues and and so
that's key he also talks about something
else that i think is really
interesting here in this text he tells
us that
the person who wants to be a cynic
ought first to censure severely
and cross-examine himself and without
any self-flattery
ask himself the following questions in
precise terms so
we could say to be very crude no
bullshitting
you're going to like look at yourself in
the
unvarnished harsh light of the sun
and ask yourself where are you really so
here's the questions
he says do you enjoy expensive food
can you do without a soft bed are you
the slave of rewards
and the opinion of other people is it
your ambition to attract
public notice and even though that be an
empty honor
still think it worthwhile right these
are the things that you need to
think about you need to question
yourself about and if you do that you
can say
oh yeah man i do
want that stuff and then you can start
to attack it now you can actually bring
to bear
the resources of reason against it
so this leads us then to the problems
that julian is diagnosing in
contemporary cynics remember
this is an oration to the uneducated
cynics
he's telling these people man you're
doing it wrong you're getting things
screwed up
so how are they how are they going
astray
he talks about them and he uses certain
terms
shameless impudent scorners
and he you know he uses examples of
particular people who are doing this
this sort of stuff you know this is not
what crotase
or diogenes or antisthenes or even plato
or aristotle
were engaging in but there are some
contemporary cynics
that are like this right they're
scorning other people
now they're doing something that
diogenes himself
often did or anticipates did but they're
doing it in the wrong way for the wrong
reasons
he says that they're like brute animals
and by this he doesn't
mean just that they are trying to live
in an uncultivated way as possible and
you know
pee in the open like dogs or you know
eat raw meat or stuff like that
he means that they are not
mastering that emotional
and desirous part of ourselves they're
slaves to their appetites
so if diogenes as he did
masturbates in the marketplace and says
afterwards oh if it was only so easy to
appease my hunger by rubbing my belly
that could have some sort of point of
like teaching a lesson to people
about you know social conventions but a
lot of these people are doing that
because they they enjoy getting off
or they enjoy stealing other people's
food or they want to show off
and get you know the the approval of the
crowd that's not the
cynic lifestyle another thing he talks
about is in
indulging in what we can translate as
freedom of speech or frankness of speech
parasia in greek meaning the capacity to
say whatever you want to people
and he says that no this is something
you actually have to earn
and he's got an interesting example here
of a case where diogenes uh
here's this this guy
here we go once when in a crowd of
people among whom was diogenes a certain
youth made an unseemly noise
diogenes struck him with his staff and
said and so vile wretch though you have
done
nothing that would give you the right to
take such liberties in public
you're beginning here and before us to
show us your scorn
of opinion there's other places where he
talks about you know this freedom of
speech
that you you you know the cynic
has to earn it they have to show that
they
are in a certain sense above they're not
just a buffoon
to ridicule people or stuff like that
there's another
really great section here where he talks
about the costume of
cynics and he tells us let him who
wishes to be a cynic philosopher
not adopt merely their long cloak or
wallet or staff or their way of wearing
the hair
as though you were like a man walking uh
in
shaved and illiterate in a villa that
that village that lacked barber shops
and schools
instead let him consider that reason
rather than a staff
and a certain plan of life rather than a
wallet are the mint marks of the cynic
philosophy it's not what you wear it's
not what you dress
it's not putting on the costume it's not
making a show
that actually makes you a cynic it is
cultivating yourself philosophically
disciplining the body
even disciplining the soul and then
you're entitled to behave like a cynic
and and do all the sorts of things that
they do because you're not a fraud
you're not a charlatan you're not
putting on
heirs so this is
how julian is is framing what it means
to
really be a cynic it involves discipline
and it's aimed at a genuine kind of
happiness
that can only be enjoyed by those who do
undergo
that discipline through philosophy
you